Que creo que es 1 ejercicio de transparencia,
de democracia interna,
que es ejemplar.
Y desde luego yo
como secretario general del partido socialista Euskadi,
Euskadi koskarra,
tengo que decir que me siento muy orgulloso
de este tipo de de ejercicios.
No soy de los que me escondo.
Hace 1 momento acabo de depositar
mi voto
como militante de la agrupación socialista de Eibar,
1 voto favorable
a la confección
de 1 gobierno progresista que abra 1 Nuevo tiempo
en España y
que continúe con la hoja de ruta
del gobierno progresista
que ha estado gobernando este país
durante la pasada legislatura.
Desde luego mi sí es 1 sí
en favor de la normalización política de Cataluña,
pero es 1 sí que VA mucho más allá.
Es 1 sí a la revalorización de las pensiones,
a la subida de las becas para estudiantes,
a la subida del salario mínimo interprofesional,
a la aplicación de nuevas políticas
basadas en la ley de vivienda,
a los descuentos al transporte,
1 sí que apueste por el futuro de nuestros jóvenes,
que cuida a nuestros mayores,
que refuerce la sanidad pública
y la educación pública en este país.
En definitiva, es 1 sí a 1 Nuevo futuro,
a 1 Nuevo horizonte que siga situando a España
donde está actualmente,
que es en la vanguardia,
siendo ejemplo absolutamente
para muchos países de la Unión Europea.
Por tanto, yo creo que hoy es 1 jornada feliz
en la que estoy convencido
que la militancia socialista
respaldará desde Luego
la posición y el camino emprendido por nuestro partido
a nivel federal